in any other election the WikiLeaks
release of emails and private speeches
from the Clinton campaign would be a
huge deal but Donald Trump's trainwreck
campaign filled with allegations of his
sexually predatory behavior has
deflected attention away from it
that doesn't mean Hillary Clinton should
get a free pass on what she said behind
closed doors especially when that's
different than what she's told the
American people the WikiLeaks dumps of
emails and documents reveal Clinton told
Wall Street bankers that it's important
to hold both public and private
positions
she even defended that view in the
second presidential debate where she
referenced the Steven Spielberg movie
Lincoln it was a master class watching
President Lincoln get the Congress to
approve the Thirteenth Amendment
it was principled and it was strategic
and I was making the point that it is
hard sometimes to get the Congress to do
what you want to do now the Clinton
campaign hasn't confirmed the
authenticity of these emails but they
haven't denied them either so just how
different are those public and private
views well here are four times when
public Clinton and private Clinton
weren't saying the same things first
there's wall street Americans are still
reeling from the effects of the 2008
recession brought on by Wall Street
recklessness and in her speech at the
DNC Clinton vowed that it wouldn't
happen again
I believe Wall Street can never ever be
allowed to wreck Main Street again but
Clinton has been paid millions to give
speeches on Wall Street and thanks to
the leaks we know that she was a bit
more sympathetic to the bankers saying
that blaming Wall Street for the
economic crash was an oversimplification
she also told those same bankers that
they be the ones telling Washington how
to fix the economy then their Syria in
the second presidential debate Clinton
talked about her support for no-fly
zones and safe zones in the war-torn
country so I when I was Secretary of
State
advocate
and I advocate today a no-fly zone and
safe zones but as far back as 2013 she
was admitting in private speeches that
there were some serious drawbacks to
that strategy namely that Syrian
anti-missile defense systems are located
in highly populated areas and Clinton
said that means you're going to kill a
lot of civilians then there's free trade
free trade has been a big issue this
election and Clinton has come out
against the trans-pacific partnership
saying it doesn't meet her standards for
creating American jobs
she's also stressed the importance of
free trade deals that protects Americans
I have said from the very beginning that
we had to have a trade agreement that
would create good American jobs raised
wages and advance our national security
and I still believe that's the high bar
we have to meet but that's not what she
said when she spoke to a Brazilian Bank
in 2013 there she praised the idea of
open borders and unrestricted trade
without any mention of fairness for
workers American or otherwise
and finally there's fracking one Clinton
campaign ad touts her record on clean
energy and gives the impression that she
supports community efforts to ban
fracking as president she'll invest in a
clean energy future and the jobs that go
with it and stand firm with New Yorkers
of opposing fracking
giving communities the right to say no
but that's not true
not only does she have a record of
supporting fracking as Secretary of
State in 2015 she told union workers
that she planned to support natural gas
and that anti-fracking activists should
get a life Clinton already has a trust
problem with voters and this information
doesn't do a lot to help that it shows
her as a savvy politician who knows how
to alter her words for her audience but
it's not clear which views will make it
into her policies and when the other
side is such a disaster well any of this
actually matter